now welcome to this video playing a five
minute blitz game and um it's down the
auto pairing system if you look at the
bottom right I'm very close to 2500 and
for those kind of games well it's about
those those rating barriers they are
always tricky in my experience okay so
then we got a slob the the wood main
line is played Bishop 26 mm I don't
really have notice too well but I am I
think this might be a good idea trying
to to get the bishop okay so probably
the rook usually belongs on d1 how to
continue now probably here this makes it
difficult home to play 5sg successor
what it's always funny you say difficult
then it plays it anyway okay I'm if I
take on g6 he can maybe take twice on c3
and I've got too much hanging but what
about night a to thirst its toll it's so
hang on g6 of surprising he simply m
gives away the bishop get what how to
hard to not take it okay if I go look
before this Queenie one
so annoying move be three I can take III
okay he takes you for maybe 95 does not
lead to too much I'm not sure maybe I
should simply play here and then then
take on g6 next move maybe type 26 now
you can try I forgot about that move
okay well I can do to see too but it's
not what I wanted yeah don't know what
what is this is equal on he has a
potential very nice square d phi for the
night of course but i don't really know
check
okay so i can probably take the pawn so
yeah I hope that my bishop is still the
better piece but it's not done it's not
great especially considering the time
situation now you should probably just
take it and play 95 slaughter some easy
easy solution and probably all right
okay look before this going to be five
we will put the knight on d5 anyway I
need to me to get the King into the game
95 I'll just jump thought the lighter
would go to d5 white is going I don't
know I had a stable position on d5 I
don't know why is trying to place the
night somewhere else
this is some now looking looking like
some advantage but it's not down not
easy let's just keep it keep it simple
so it's equal but don't have so much
time can you look before I here we can
take it check I don't mind I've I've got
very good activity with King and King a
drug I can get the ball it's no big deal
check and I'll see five or so c5 is the
problem King be 65 very lucky he didn't
didn't foresee that of course yeah just
a coincidence okay but them it's though
it's still quite active for me okay I'll
take on f6 smut not leading to much rg5
she takes rook c6 King c6 king before
yeah so doesn't lead to much
unfortunately check check time wording
who have six King e5 check quite nice my
dad Fred and look at four check check yo
and white is winning black resigns oh
yeah no I'm 17 seconds and i know it was
so it was tricky does endgame but it
still seems like a white should be ok
check here you can place if I back from
with a with the draw draw drawing a king
a pawn in game ok this should be ok I
mean probably equal check check yeah
this is very Jewish actually
yahoo beautifies them Sir it's good oh
cool the computer gives a cool line it
says the rook takes they have six or so
drawn ok this is possible they're two
pawns ok what he didn't manage to my at
1 minute 40 could have invested a bit of
time let's say let's check this briefly
oh it's how this is a strong rook takes
tragic and now the palm is so as
marching to hear a three now I simply I
cannot approach with the King this is
the problem can you do all kinds of
checks but it doesn't lead to much just
is too too quick even here now it's a
job I need to I have no way to stop the
porn i need at some point you do and
don't get it back yeah good fight and i
managed to 52 505 now this is a record
for this account it's not an overall I'm
record for me I had to 570 ones with the
with a non non commentary account yeah
thanks for watching this game was quite
interesting